[Music]
now we have begun to speak of the
tartars
i have plenty to tell you on that
[Music]
subject
the tartar custom is to spend the winter
in warm plains
where they find good pasture for their
cattle whilst in summer they betake
themselves to a cool climate
among the mountains and valleys where
water is to be found as well as woods
and pastures
they live on the milk and meat which
their herds supply
and on the produce of the chase and they
eat
all kinds of flesh including that of
horses and dogs and
pharaoh's rats of which there are great
numbers in burrows on these planes
their drink is mare's milk they are very
careful not to meddle with each other's
wives
and will not do so on any account
holding that to be an
evil and abominable thing the women too
are very good and loyal to their
husbands and
notable housewives with all 10 or
20 of them will dwell together in
charming peace and unity
nor shall you ever hear an ill word
among them
all their harness of war is excellent
and costly
their arms are bow and arrows swords and
maces
but above all the bow for they are
capital archers
indeed the best that are known on their
backs they wear
armor prepared from buffalo and other
hides which is
very strong they are excellent soldiers
and
passing valiant in battle they are also
more capable of hardships than other
nations for many a time if needs be
they will go for a month without any
supply of food
living only on the milk of their mares
and on such game as their bows may win
for them
their horses also will subsist entirely
on the grass of the plains
so there is no need to carry a store of
barley or
straw or oats and they are very docile
to their riders
these in case of need will abide on
horseback
to live long night armed at all points
while the horse will be continually
grazing
when a tartare prince goes forth to war
he takes with him
say a hundred thousand horses
well he he appoints an officer to every
ten men
one to every hundred one to every
thousand and one to every ten
thousand so that his own orders have to
be given to ten persons only
and each of these ten persons has to
pass the orders only to another ten
and so on no one having to give orders
to more than ten
and every one in turn is responsible
only to the officer
immediately over him and the discipline
and order that comes out of this method
is marvellous for they are a people very
obedient to their chiefs
this video is sponsored by squarespace a
great choice if you want to increase
your online presence
squarespace is a big supporter of
history content and education in general
on youtube
and if you aren't so good with
technology like me
they are an invaluable tool when it
comes to setting up your slick looking
website
with an easy to use interface and
blogging tools to help elevate your
website
from this to this head over to
squarespace.com
for your free trial and when you are
ready to launch go to squarespace.com
forward slash voices
to get 10 off thanks
and when the army is on the march they
always have 200 horsemen
very well mounted who are sent a
distance of two marches in advance to
check the area
and these always keep ahead
when they are going on a distant
expedition they take no gear with them
except
two leather bottles for milk a little
earthenware pot to cook their meat in
and a little tent to shelter them from
the rain and in case of great
urgency they will ride 10 days on end
without lighting a fire or taking a meal
on such an occasion they will sustain
themselves on the blood
of their horses opening a vein and
letting the blood eject into their
mouths
drinking till they have had enough and
then staunching it
when they come to an engagement with the
enemy they will gain the victory in this
fashion
they never let themselves get into a
regular medley but keep
perpetually riding round and shooting
into the enemy
and as they do not counted any shame to
run away from battle
they will sometimes pretend to do so
and in running away they turn in the
saddle and
shoot hard and strong at the foe and in
this way
cause great havoc their horses
are trained so perfectly that they will
double hither and thither just like a
dog
in a way that is quite astonishing
thus they fight to as good purpose in
running away
as if they stood and faced the enemy
because of the vast
volleys of arrows that they shoot in
this way turning round upon their
pursuers
who are fancying that they have won the
battle
all this that i have been telling you is
true of the manners and customs of the
genuine
tartars but i must also add that
in these days they are greatly
degenerated for those who are settled in
cathay
have taken up the practices of the
idolaters of the country
and have abandoned their own
institutions
whilst those who have settled in the
levant have adopted the customs
of the saracens
now i have told you about the manners
and customs of the tartars
you have heard nothing yet of the great
state
of the grand khan who is the lord of all
the tartars and the supreme
imperial court the personal appearance
of the great
khan lord of lords whose name is kublai
is such as i shall now tell you he is of
a good stature
neither tall or short but of a middle
height
he has a becoming amount of flesh and is
very
shapely in all his limbs his complexion
is
white and red the eye is black and fine
the nose well formed and well set on
[Music]
he has four wives who he retains
permanently as
his legitimate consorts and the eldest
of his sons by those four wives
ought by rights to be the emperor i mean
when his father dies
those four ladies are called empresses
but each is distinguished also by her
proper name
and each of them has a special court of
her own very grand and ample
no one of them having fewer than 300
fair and charming damsels
he has also a great number of concubines
you must know that there is a tribe of
tartars called ungrat
who are noted for their beauty now
every year a hundred of the most
beautiful maidens of this tribe
are sent to the great khan who commits
them to the charge of certain elderly
ladies dwelling in his palace
and these old ladies make the girls
sleep with them
in order to ascertain if they have sweet
breath
and do not snore and are sound in all
their limbs
then such of them as our approved beauty
and our good and sound in all respects
are appointed to attend on the emperor
by turns to serve him in
any way and to be entirely at his orders
and so throughout the year there are
reliefs of maidens by six and six
changing every three days and nights
you must know that for three months of
the year to wit
december january and february the great
khan resides in the capital city
of cathay which is called kambar luke
and which is in the north eastern
extremity of the country
and that city stands his great palace
now there was on that spot in old times
a great and noble city called
kambaluk which is as much as to say in
our tongue
the city of the emperor but the great
khan was informed by his astrologers
that this city would prove rebellious
and raise
great disorders against his imperial
authority
so he caused the present city to be
built close beside
the old one with only a river between
them
and he caused the people of the old city
to be removed to the new town
that he had founded and this is called
taidu
you must know that the city of kambaluk
has such a multitude of houses
and such a vast population inside the
walls and outside
that it seems quite past all possibility
there is a suburb outside each of the
gates which are 12 in number
and these suburbs are so great that they
contain
more people than the city itself
there are in each of the suburbs to a
distance of a mile from the city
numerous fine hostelries for the
lodgement of merchants from different
parts of the world
and a special hostelry is assigned to
each description of people
as if we should say there is one for the
lombards
another for the germans and the third
for the frenchman
you must know that it is forbidden to
bury any dead body inside the city
if the body be that of an idolater it is
carried out
beyond the city and suburbs to a remote
place
assigned for the purpose to be burnt and
thus the city is preserved in a better
and more healthy state moreover no
public woman resides inside the city
but all such abide outside in the
suburbs
and is wonderful what a vast number of
these there
are for the foreigners
the emperor's mint then is in this same
city of kambaluk
and the way it is wrought is such that
you might say
he hath the secret of alchemy and
perfection
and you would be right for he makes his
money
after this fashion he makes them take of
the bark of a certain
tree in fact uh the mulberry tree
the leaves of which are the food of the
silkworms
and this they make into something
resembling sheets of
paper but black when these sheets have
been prepared
they are cut up into pieces of different
sizes the smallest of these sizes is
worth
a half tonsil a little larger one tonsil
one a little larger still is worth half
a silver growth of venice
another a whole groat other yet two
groats etc etc
anyone forging it would be punished with
death
with these pieces of paper made as i've
described
he causes all payments on his own
account to be made
and he makes them to pass currency
universally
over all his kingdoms and provinces and
territories
and nobody however important he may
think himself
dares to refuse them on pain of death
[Music]
now i will tell you of his arms and
great charity
to the poor in the city of kambaluk
you see he causes selection to be made
of a number of families in the city
who are in a state of poverty and of
such families some may consist of
six in the house some of eight some of
ten
and each family he causes annually to be
supplied
with wheat and other corn sufficient for
the whole year
and this he never fails to do every year
and so some 30 000 people go for it
every day from year's end to year's end
now this is a great goodness in the
emperor to take
pity of his poor people thus and they
benefit
so much by it that they worship him as
if he were god
[Music]
you